now I read something that James Corden
was being considered for the role at
some point did you read that at all have
you ever heard that before yeah yeah I
did I I is there any truth I if he says
so I mean I know that Darren um looked
for 10 years to find an actor to fill
this part and I'm sure there were 10
years yeah why 10 years he saw the whale
in 2012. it was that New Horizon here in
New York and so he took his time because
he wanted to cast the role
um I guess
I won't speak foreign but effectively
you know and and the challenge that he
was really open with me about when I met
him initially was how am I going to do
this I need to find well an actor who
can act but at the same time has a
physical body type that can create
Charlie that builds him from the outside
in so to speak yeah he and to do that he
was really forthcoming about we're going
to use Adrian Moreau who is a longtime
collaborator of his and wizard with um
Prosthetics yeah they I was uh impressed
with the I don't know how they added the
300 pounds to you but uh makeup it's
like costume but that's got to be when
you go to shoot a scene they got to put
you in this stuff how many hours are you
sitting in a chair getting this uh four
hours yeah and and what are you doing
when you're sitting there looking at
YouTube videos of Street cooking in
Korea normally stop thinking really yeah
it's just gassy that's your thing or
whatever whatever crap comes up on
Reddit or one of the things I had read
was that Darren Aronofsky said also he
was interested in taking someone who was
so such a big star and then sort of I
want to revive their career he wanted to
ReDiscover Brendan Fraser and was that
true do you know that that's a fact he
did tell me that it would be helpful to
him to hire an actor who
um everyone felt they already knew but
they hadn't seen in a while
and to reintroduce whoever that is and
that's what he told me in our initial
meeting and of course I was like it's me
please let it be me in my mind but I
didn't know if I had the job or not and
I understood what he was saying because
it's fair I I was in everyone's living
room for a while in the 90s there I was
like the furniture to a whole generation
of young people now who have kids of
their own I'm old but it made sense that
he was looking towards someone because
Charlie should feel like he's someone
that you know everybody should be able
to identify with him and people can do
that I can see I've learned that they
can do that with me with Brandon and
also on top of that
I saw what he did with Mickey in the
wrestler and that was brilliant and
Mickey brilliant brilliant he was just
right it was perfect they always say
though that a good director is a guy who
doesn't
um tell the actors what to do when you
finally get the role and you start to
rehearse
he doesn't sit there and give you notes
to death right he'll let you do your
thing we would find it together he went
over the script meticulously line by
Limer line he and I went on Zoom
sessions and um we learned it I like I
told you I
got off book as best I could but like
like all the best directors Darren's
very simple about just showing you where
to go to get to where you need to be I
mean that's what a director does
essentially it's over there just go over
there and if you take that direction
maybe something good will happen